like I said this amount is how much it
actually costs and then tax cuts are
done but in Australia as I mentioned
usually GST is just included on the
label it's there you don't have to do
this calculation okay so what if you
wanted to know how much the GST of an
object were okay so we've got this
situation here suppose the tablet has a
price tag on it that says okay so we
already know because we just [ __ ] it
up we know the answer we expect how much
the chassis is but how do you reverse
engineer this to get to go backwards
through this situation so I want to give
me your suggestions you take this Dan
your dram shot it today okay I know why
did you can't so everyone don't have to
jump in yeah well how are we going to
get from this like I'm not just
interested in the answer I know what the
answer is but I want to know how to get
this so later on when I don't know I can
approach it in the particular way Rachel
Dratch shot sorry I'm gonna write down
what I'm calculating you said divide the
913 by okay now let's write this down
and pause for a second okay
this seems like a sensible idea for
starters because like we did something
like this before when we work here GST
right that's good but do you remember
okay what this is going to give us is
10% but it's going to give us 10% of
this amount it will not give us 10% of
this which is where the GST comes from
does that make sense so even though
divided by 10 seems like a good
intuitive first way to go
in fact will not give us the entry
dollars we were after so it's a good
shot but what else could we try yeah
come on pause before you go on okay
do you see how we drew that conclusion
you see how I got that because this
there's a hundred percent and then we
just went up ten percent so this is a
hundred and ten percent
okay so so far so good no one well we
can work it we've got this help us
that's the sale price on the ticket okay
so I suppose what we want is either the
original price or the GST once you've
got one you've got the other don't you
okay so even though it's just like would
you okay so dividing by ten was very
close right but in fact divided by
eleven will be better because you're in
a ministry method remember the unitary
we looked at before if you've got like
seventeen percent of something right if
you divide that by whatever number it is
you'll get one percent because GST is a
specific percentage ayah what one I want
ten so to get from this to ten percent
I should divide by 11 does that make
sense 210 divided by eleven now to give
me ten percent
if you are using the entry method you
divide by 110 to get 1% but we actually
what tip is it yeah okay so now you
don't need to reach your calculators
because we in fact already know the
answer but if you want you can double
check 113 divided by 11 is going to give
you 83 and in fact if you go to the
supermarket and you divide any good that
you are going to buy you divide it by 11
there's that little portion that will be
there GST in fact and here's actually
we'd like you to stand in computers the
next time you and your parents go to the
shops okay you know usually like if
you're going to sell check out there
like you under a st. you-let's get the
receipt okay and when you look at it
GST gets pulled out they actually show
you how much is to gets calculated and
they do it in this way okay it's also
important because sometimes extra some
items have extra tax and so on and on
this is actually useful for your tax
purposes only